I'm a big fan of your son such he's
grown into such a good-looking smart
charming young man he just turned 21
yeah
and I'm curious that's a big birthday do
you have to do something crazy special I
get him a blimp ride or something on his
21st birthday what do you do for 21 well
he just wanted to have dinner with his
friends and let my husband and I come
oh and then I offered like well I can
take you to Las Vegas and we can go
gambling and I don't know why go to
Vegas with his mom so he turned you off
we're sick 21 year old wands yeah I'm
going to Vegas with my mom okay here's
what I do know about you another thing I
know that you okay you like to gamble
yeah I think you invited him to go to
Las Vegas because that's what you wanted
to do you didn't care what Julian wanted
to do you were like let's go let's go
gambling that's what you like that's
right yeah but you have a lot of
self-control so you love to gamble but
you you keep a lid on it right yeah I
bring a certain amount of money that I
am allowed to lose and then if I lose it
all I borrow from my husband he's been
an ATM yeah but no cuz I do I try to be
careful cuz we have been it seems to be
an issue in my family what was that yeah
I have my grandfather my mother's father
died in Vegas at a table gambling this
is a true story yeah that's true and
when did this this happened quite a
while 1949 wow you know it's like 49
yeah no he died he was playing some game
club osh or something it's like a
Hungarian card game that okay so they
had Club Bosch tables in Vegas in 1949
so I could look this up I mean not many
people dropped it at the club Bosch tape
I know
I'm saying it right here I tried looking
it up I can't find it so of course I go
to maybe he was murdered
what no I do that too I always think
when something when anyone dies it could
the person could be 140 years old coma
and they died at a hospital I'm like it
was murder
do you this is a I mean this is a really
that's a dark story but he died must
have been obviously very upsetting at
the time for everybody did they find out
what I don't know because well yeah I
guess it was upsetting let's just say
yes it was upsetting yeah it was
upsetting yeah but you're not telling me
everything
I know I know I can't oh you can't I
can't
oh no you're not gonna pull that on me
Mandy sounds like she's a mafia princess
yeah well okay